USA
let's do another one baby
hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmc control
mp.l2-3.8.6 Implement cryptographic
mechanisms to protect the
confidentiality of cui stored on digital
media during transport unless otherwise
protected by alternative physical
safeguards
WTF
[Music]
say if you're a defense contractor who's
feeling overwhelmed tired and alone
trying to understand all of this cmmc
dfars and nist sp-800 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you
you found your home here at on-call
compliance Solutions where we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's Don the
cape and jump into it
it's done to keep and jump into action I
don't know sure good enough for me all
right so I'm going to give you a brief
lesson here on how to protect cui then
go dive back into how to answer this
control because it's all very relevant
so like really what I'm saying is I'm
going to do a Quentin Tarantino on how I
answer this because it's way more fun
than just giving you the answer here we
go uh there are two count them one two
ways to protect cui you guys know I love
the count how can I let the count I love
the count anyway if you don't know what
the count is
I'm counting you out uh look two ways to
protect cui number one physical
protection you've physically protected
number two in situations where you
cannot physically protect it which by
the way is preferred you must encrypt it
to protect it okay those are the only
two ways to protect cui now that we
understand that what this control is all
about is making sure you understand that
if cui is going to be digitally
transported and email is an example then
that email must be encrypted because you
cannot physically protect an email
during transmission
vpns and wireless networks are other
examples of this situation where
encryption is required because you can't
physically protect the cui as it's in
transit through a VPN or a wireless
network or any other situation like that
all right let's dive in and see what the
assessors are looking for on this one
what are they looking for they're
looking to determine if the
confidentiality of cui stored on digital
media is protected during transport
using cryptographic mechanisms or
alternative physical safeguards note
that it does not say determine the
confidence value of cui stored on
digital media is protected during uh
uh storage doesn't say that so it
doesn't have to be encrypted in storage
unless it's on a mobile device because
there's a separate control for that but
the point is is that it's only really
concerned on this control uh with it
during transport
Implement cui stored on digital media is
always physically protected via the it
use and cyber security policy in
addition the organization utilizes
encrypted media during transport now
that's optional but that's what we're
doing to satisfy that control uh as we
give the imaginary sample answer there
all right so hey at on call we work with
defense contractors just like you who
have had this defar's nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff drop their laps like a
seagull on a sunny day baby splat now we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on call compliance hero to your
company eliminating gaps great areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that is
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you if you're looking for
more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc compliance
secrets.com or check out the bio below
for links to get help right now if you
love the content we're putting out here
for you help us out with a big thumbs up
on that like button or even better smash
the Subscribe button to make sure that
you find out when the compliance stores
at our company are rolling out that
content and I said that backwards but
I'm Gonna Roll With It forwards until
the next compliance tip my friends stay
safe and secure out there and hit us in
the comments below to let us know what
you'd like to know more about when it
comes to information security and
compliance boom I'll see you on the next
one
[Music]
thank you anyway